اذا ما زالت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع تتصدر المشهد
خصوصا في مدينه الخرطوم بحري وذلك بعد
اسبوع من اندلاعها وفي اول ايام عيد الفطر
اعلنت قوه الدعم السريع موافقتها على هدنه
انسانيه بناء على دعوات محليه ودوليه هذه
الاشتباكات تنعكس سلبا على حياه المواطنين
على مختلف الصعود في ظل تحذيرات من انهيار
القطاع الصحي ولمزيد من التطورات تنضم
الينا شبكه مراسلينا من الخرطوم هيثم اويت
من مدخل جسر الصداقه في مروي في شمال
السودان مراسل الجزيره اسامه سيد احمد
هيثم
نبدا معك
اخر التفاصيل سواء حول الالتزام بالهدنه
او الوضع الانساني
جلال هذه الهدنه لم تدخل حيز التنفيذ اصلا
باعتبار ان الجانب الذي
طرحه والتزم بها هو جانب واحد حتى الان
ولكن
الهدنه فعليا لم تطبق ما زالت العمليات
المسلحه الجاريه في بعض الاماكن خاصه
منطقه البحري وكانت هنا قبل قليل في وايضا
وسط الخرطوم ولا نزل في هذه الاثناء نسمع
العدويه انفجارات لمناطق بعيده ربما في ام
درمان هذه الهدنه يعني حتى انها اعلنت
بالامس ويفترض ان تدخل منذ السادسه صباح
اليوم ولكن لم تدخل حيز التنفيذ وما تزال
الاوضاع تتفاقم سواء كانت هذه الاوضاع
الميدانيه على مستوى المعارك والمواجهات
المسلحه المستمره او على مستوى المعاناه
الانسانيه المتفاقبه بالتوازي مع هذا
الاشتباك المستمر خاصه
في وسط الخرطوم سواء كان بالقرب من اماكن
الاشتباكات الجاريه والمواجهات قرب
المواقع الاستراتيجيه القصر الجمهوري
نتحدث عن ايضا القياده العامه للجيش وعن
المطار او سواء في المناطق التي ايضا تقع
في نطاق بقرب من المواقع العسكريه في
مواقع اخرى شلل تام للحياه في كثير من
المناطق جاء العيد دون فرحه العيد
المعتاده لم يعني في مناطق محدوده جدا
استطاع الناس ان يتحركوا ان يؤدوا صلاه
العيد وان كان لم تكن بما هو عليه في
السابق ولكن هنا في وسط الخرطوم تحديدا
والاماكن المجاوره الشوارع تخلو تماما من
الماره لا يوجد اي مصاري من مظاهر الحياه
الشلل التام يصيب الحياه ويصيب هذه
الاماكن الجسور ما زالت مغلقه الحركه فيها
غير موجوده خاصه الجسور القريبه من مواقع
وسط الخرطوم الرابطه البحري والخرطوم وام
درمان والخرطوم ولكن الاعمال ما زالت
معقوده على ان تفعل هذه الهدنه خاصه وان
الدعوات لهذه الهدنه تتعالى من قبل الجهات
عديده خاصه المجتمع الدولي
نتحدث عن الامم المتحده وعن الدول الاتحاد
الافريقي ومجموعه من الدول الاخرى التي
تطالب وتضغط الطرفين على ضروره الالتزام
بوقف التصعيد ووقف اطلاق النار واتاحه
فرصه لايجاد حل سلمي بدل هذا
الحل العسكري الذي يعني يستمر ويتفاقم ولا
يتلوح في الافق اي بوادر لنهائيات يمكن ان
تنتهي عليها هذه المواجهات ومزيد من
التدمير ومزيد من الخراب والدمار الذي يصل
به السودانيين الان يعني كل الامور تتوقع
ان تكون هناك اختراق لجعل الهدنه ممكنه ان
الجيش يعلن عن نشر الالاف من جنو ده
للقيام بعمليه مسح في الخرطوم ما هو
المقصود بعمليه مسح في الخرطوم وما الهدف
من ذلك
هذه العمليه التي اعلن عنها الجيش المرحله
الثانيه كما تحدث الجيش في بيانات للناطق
الرسميه له وهي تشمل مساله يعني مطارده من
سماهم بالقوات المتمرده في العاصمه وفي
الاحياء وهي كما يقول الجيش انها مرحله
ملاحقه ومطارده القوات المتمرده واخراجها
لخارج العاصمه
وبسطي سيطرته على
المناطق الاخرى غير المناطق الاستراتيجيه
هذا يعني ان الجيش الان ينتشر في الاحياء
خاصه ان بعض هذه القوات لها مواقع التمركز
في العديد من الاحياء وبالقرب من المواقع
السكنيه وايضا في المواقع الحكوميه
المرافق الحكوميه الخدميه هتتمركز فيها
قوات الدعم والسريع وبالتالي الجيش من
خلال ما اعلنه انه يقوم بملاحقه هذه
القوات في هذه المواقع واجبارها واخراجها
العاصمه الجيش كان يتحدث بانه يحاول ان
يقلل العمليات العسكريه داخل الاحياء خوفه
من ان تقع او يقع المزيد من الضحايا في
هذا الصراع وان القتال في الاماكن السكنيه
لديه نتائج كارثيه على المواطنين وبالتالي
يحاول ان يقلل هذه الخسائر وهو يقوم
بعمليه نشر عمليه
قوات بريه وقوات راجله داخل الاحياء تقوم
وهما يتم الان في خاصه في منطقه الخرطوم
بحري وهو ما يعنيه الجيش من خلال هذه
المرحله الثانيه من العمليه العسكريه
والتي يقول بانها ستنهي هذا هذه العمليه
العسكريه في مساله التمر داخل الخرطوم
وربما تؤسس لمرحله جديده سيعلن عنها لاحقا